You know,
from a strictly scientific perspective,
we think of human beings has nothing but the children of nature and culture.
And that pushes you towards a kind of deterministic view.
What causes your behavior?
Well,
it's either nature or culture because there isn't anything else.
But that isn't how the mythological story lays itself out because it says there
is something else and that's whatever your consciousness is.
And that consciousness seems to be able to work with nature and culture in a non
deterministic manner in order to bring well in order for what?
In order to bring itself forward.
I mean,
and that's really what's interesting about that I think is that it isn't
obviously just the plot of Pinocchio,
it's virtually the plot of any story is the story of the development of the
individual.
Now the story is order chaos,
higher order,
roughly speaking.
So you can get variants of that.
You can get order collapses into disorder and nothing is resolved.
That's a tragedy,
right?
And,
and you can get so,
so you don't have to have the entire story represented in his story,
but you get fragments of it.
It's a classic.
You shaped story and what it is is the story of the development of the
individual across time as a consequence of his or her adventures in time and
space.
And every story is exactly that.
And those are representations of the manner in which you come to be in the world
for better or for worse.
It's differentiated.
So the individual has a negative and a pause.
Development and culture has a negative and a pause.
Development and nature does as well,
and that makes the potential for plots much broader.
But I think it's also very useful to know that entire story because I think it's
one of the things that protects you against ideology.
It's like,
okay.
Whereas if someone tells you a political story or a story of any sort,
you can always ask,
well,
where are the missing characters?
Human beings are terrible.
They've erected a culture that's destroying the planet and nature is beneath,
you know,
benevolent and and pristine.
It's like,
yeah,
fair enough.
Accurate.
But you're missing half the characters because humans are not just terrible
rapacious creatures.
And culture is not just a destructive force in nature,
is by no means on our side.
So where's the missing characters?
You need all of the characters in the representation to get it right.
And I really believe this to be true.
So for example,
if you want to protect yourself against trauma as you move forward in life,
you have to be very aware of the three,
three negative characters.
You have to know that the human individual has an adversarial element that's
malevolent right to the core.
And if you don't know that and you run across someone who's malevolent,
you will end up damaged.
So because first you won't be able to defend yourself.
You'll just be like a ripe fruit tree for the plucking and second,
the mere existence of someone like that will pose such a to the way that you've
organized the world,
that it might collapse on you.
That happens to people all the time.
So it really matters whether you know these categories and it matters that you
know that culture can become tyrannical.
It really,
but that it's also you're the father that's given you everything.
And it matters that you know,
everything good comes from nature and that we need to live in harmony with
nature to some degree.
But that it's also a hell bent on our destruction every second.
And it's very paradoxical.
It's a,
it's a hard thing to reconcile with,
with,
with uh,
without a thought structure like modern science that's based on a strict logic
that always says something can't be itself and its opposite at the same time.
But you know,
human beings can certainly be something and its opposite at the same time and
anything truly complex can have that and does have that nature.
If someone offers you a new job,
you think,
well that's positive.
It's like no it's not.
It's positive and negative and complex.
It might be the solution to your problem but at the same set time it's going to
generate a whole host of other problems.
So lots of times we're,
we're,
we're encountering entities in some sense that have an internally paradoxical
structure and we have to deal with that entire set of paradoxes or,
or we don't survive.
It's really a matter of survival.
Okay.
So,
so I'm,
and then you know,
there's this overarching symbol,
which is the dragon of chaos,
which is potential itself.
And it's the potential from which all of these categories emerge.
And so the,
the,
the most abstract category of our imagination is that,
which is beyond our understanding the category of that which is beyond our
understanding.
And that seems to me to be represented because we can only use the
representational structures that we evolved,
is that it's represented in our paradoxical representation of the Predator and
the treasure that lies beyond the perimeter,
that perimeter perimeters of our safe societies.
So what's out there beyond,
well,
we don't know,
but we need to know because we need always to deal with what we don't know.
So weirdly enough,
we have to come up with a category of what we don't know in order to start
formalizing a theory about how we might progress towards it and interact with
it.
It's very paradoxical idea and there's a paradoxical answer,
right?
It's,
it's the terrible Predator that lurks in the unknown that also harbors something
of great value.
Perfect.
That's exactly right.
And I think that that is a reflection of the fact that human beings are Predator
animals and prey animals at the same time.
So what's out there in the,
in the terrible darkness,
something that can destroy you but also something that you absolutely need.
So how do you,
how do you prepare yourself for that?
And that's the ultimate question of life.
It's not how do you deal with death,
although death is a sub component of the terrible unknown,
I would say it's how do you deal with that which is beyond your understanding,
which is constantly manifesting itself in the world.
And that,
and that manifests itself every time you categorize something and the thing
escapes from the category.
And that happens most interpersonal relationships because people are so damn
complicated,
you get them figured out and box in.
You even make a contract that neither review,
we'll jump outside the box,
but you jump outside the box continually.
And that's why a relationship requires constant negotiation and
reconceptualization because you do not exhaust the person with your perceptual
categories.
And of course you don't exhaust the world with your perceptual categories ever.
This is partly why the existentialists,
they have this concept called alienation.
And the idea was that human beings become alienated from their creative
products.
So,
and that is,
and here's why it happens.
So imagine a Henry Ford makes the assembly line,
right?
So four,
it has no idea what's going to happen when he makes the assembly line.
Like,
cause he's just trying to figure out a fast way to make cars or he thinks that
what he's making his cars.
So he thinks he's making an assembly line for cars and he thinks he's making
cars.
And you think,
well what's wrong with that?
Well first of all,
the assembly line absolutely transformed the entire planet,
right?
Because it,
it brought in the era of mass cheap manufacturing.
It's like it just,
it was way more than he thought it was.
And then did he make a car?
Well,
a car is something that hypothetically takes you relatively effectively from
point a to point B.
It was really a replacement for the horse and buggy.
I mean they,
the first cars looked like that they were horseless carriages.
Well,
did he make a car while God,
it's God,
it's hard to tell what Henry Ford made.
He made a very effective way for transforming the atmosphere.
Right.
And the fact that it also happened to take you from point a to point B might be
just completely irrelevant compared to the fact that it was the internal
combustion engine and its rapid distribution completely changed the constituent,
the,
you know,
the fundamental chemical structure of the atmosphere itself.
It completely transformed cities.
It blew out the rural community.
Everyone moved to the cities,
right?
It made all the cities built around the automobile.
But then it had this tremendous political and economic significance too.
So I mean,
part of the reason that because you think well is a car is a way to get from
point a to point B.
But no,
no,
it's not a machine.
It's also the abolishment of an idea.
And it's a very strange idea.
A collectivist society would have never invented the car because the car is
predicated on the idea that you could own a conveyance that would get only you
and only you from somewhere to somewhere else without ever asking anybody for
any permission.
And so the funny thing is is when you build something like that,
those presuppositions are built into it.
And then when you export that say to Soviet Russia,
you don't get to,
they can't just take the car and leave the political implications behind the
car.
The mere fact that you step into one and drive it is an indication that you're
accepting the political,
ideological presuppositions that are part of the fact that thing even exists.
And so well that's alienation.
It's like even something you make,
you think,
well you have control over what you make because you've made it,
you understand.
It's like no you don't.
You understand a tiny fraction of it.
You launch it out in the world,
man,
and the snakes inside of it,
the hydrogen high inside of it multiplied their heads massively,
constantly and you and you and you can't really keep track of it.
And so,
so even even in your relationship with created entities,
you still see the reemergence of this underlying fundamental substructure,
right?
Even inside,
it's the,
it's the garden of Eden.
There's always a snake inside.
The thing that's walled in always,
always,
always.
Even God himself cannot get rid of the snakes in the garden.
And partly what that means is that,
you know,
the garden is a conceptual system.
It's the conceptual system within which people exist.
That's Eden is a,
is a walled garden.
Paradise means walled garden,
and it's walled because a walled garden is where people live.
Because the wall is culture and the garden is natured.
We always live in a structure that's an amalgam of nature and culture.
So we set it up so it's paradise as long as we're unconscious,
but we can't manage it because there's always something chaotic that's coming in
that we will interact with.
That's human beings.
You put a snake in the garden.
It's the first bloody thing we're going to talk to.
And for better or worse,
it makes us conscious and awake.
It makes us aware of our mortality.
It does all sorts of terrible things to us,
but that doesn't matter because that's,
that's the path that human beings have.
What chosen,
because that's the implication in that story.
And,
and it's,
it's very difficult.
It's a very difficult thing to answer because we certainly choose each other for
self awareness and consciousness and intelligence.
And I don't,
you know,
if you're,
if you're choosing a mate,
there's an arms race in human beings.
We're choosing intelligent mates especially that's especially the case for women
in relationship to men.
So,
um,
so that,
the idea that that's a choice,
well that's partly why it's eve that makes that himself conscious in the garden
of Eden,
right?
She offers him the apple.
She's the one that makes him self conscious.
And I think that's actually accurate because the evidence from the evolutionary
biologist is that human sexuals female sexual selection was one of the driving
factors that differentiated us from chimpanzees.
It's a major factor.
Chimpanzee females are not selective maters.
They go into estrus,
they'll mate with anything.
What happens is the dominant males chase the subordinate males away and so they
end up leaving more offspring.
But it's not a consequence of selection on the part of the females in human
beings.
It's completely different.
Concealed ovulation and intense selection pressure from women on men.
You have twice as many female ancestors as you have male ancestors,
and people can never have have a hard time working that out.
Arithmetically but it's not that problematic.
You just think on average,
every woman had one child,
half of men had none,
and the other half had to,
and that's approximately correct.
You average across the entire history of human sexuality.
So human males in particular are subject to a vicious selection,
pressure on the part of females.
And I also think that's partly why nature is represented symbolically as female
among human beings.
Because after all,
nature is what selects.
There's no better definition of nature then that which selects.